so I'm joined from central London by Sam
Dmitriy from the Adam Smith Institute
very good morning to you Sam thanks for
joining us here this morning on Sky News
on the face of it it seems like a pretty
good idea you look for a property you
don't want to pay the full rates that
regular tenants who are moving into
regular houses flats would have to pay
you pay at a discount price more often
than not the properties that you moving
into are quite interesting buildings and
when the owners of the property want you
to leave you leave but clearly you can
go so badly wrong yeah I see it as a
win-win-win situation it's a win for the
property owner who's very often the
council it means that they don't have to
fork out a lot of money on security it's
a win for the for the resident
themselves because they're getting I
mean that they have to be a bit intrepid
sometimes but they are getting rents for
well below the market value I mean
they're getting whole floors on on
office blocks for for you know a
fraction of the cost of what you'd have
to pay say in central London and gives
them more money to save so as Tim in
that video was doing to actually get on
the property ladder it's also a win for
the local community because it means
that they don't have these buildings
that are just sitting unattended it
means that there's still stuff going on
and some property Guardian schemes
actually have it so that the property
Guardian themselves actually helps out
and does a bit of community service
maybe at like a local allotment
something like that and so they actually
become quite active members of the
community as well given what we saw in
Rebecca's a piece there with this case
in Bristol there are examples when it
can go wrong
the tenants they're seeking a legal
action against the council so there are
examples where things don't go according
to plan and is that because the rules or
regulations that are in place regarding
property guardians are very different
they may not be as rigid they might not
be as stringent as the rules or
regulations that current tenants face
and and their landlords well I think
it's right that the rules are are less
stringent because in return for the
rules being less stringent they can get
a
Ren and sure if if it's the case that
when they sign this license and it turns
out things were promised that weren't
actually adhere to then sure that that's
definitely something that the law should
be dealing with because I mean we want
people to enforce contract right but
what we don't want I think is that they
get these for tenancy rights and some of
these schemes I mean they rely on being
able to move people out very quickly
they rely on the fact that they you know
they don't have to pay for lots and lots
of repairs lots and lots of certain
meeting certain building standards that
might be suitable for residential normal
residential places I mean they have it
costs a lot more they might have to up
the rent in that case and that that
would be a defeat for the reson all the
schemes themselves might just have to be
shut down if they can't evict people at
that shorter notice that they currently
are able to so I think it would be a
real loss for the residents themselves
actually if it were were to be the case
that they didn't have the full tenancy
if they if it were to be the case that
they had full tenancy right because I
think a lot of them just wouldn't be
staying in these properties in the first
place because it wouldn't be it wouldn't
make sense from the perspective of the
property owner and given of those points
that you've just highlighted it wouldn't
be advisable it wouldn't be it wouldn't
work for say a young family somebody you
know a couple who've got children
they've got a thing about schools I got
a thing about stability and their
responsibility to their children so just
give us an idea the type of person at
the type of group of people that going
down this route and may benefit well it
can actually be quite a mix it can be
some people who might used to have been
squatters but we're looking for saying a
bit more stable but they can't build up
an income another another big group are
artists so sometimes people want to have
studio space as well as somewhere to
live and that can be very very expensive
especially if you want to live in London
which a lot of people in the arts want
to do and he actually gives them an
opportunity to work work from home and
have that extra space but also I mean
one of the so one of my friends actually
was a was a is I think still is actually
a property Guardian and she stayed in
a disused library to me it seems quite
basic but she seems to enjoy it and
she's happy that half her rent her
income isn't going on rent and it sure
it surely that if she's willing to make
that choice which and she's happy about
it we shouldn't be imposing extra rules
and regulations that might make it less
likely that she'll have that option in
the first place but do you not think
there should be just a bit more security
a bit more protection for these people
that decide to go down this tree given
the fact that the owners could just say
to them right in two weeks time I want
you to leave you need to find somewhere
else to live I mean that they're gonna
have to completely train their lives
gonna have to look for a new place to
live in won't be further away from their
employments well I think it is all right
to have it as the to take these people
say give them only two weeks because
when they sign the initial contract they
know that's the deal and they know and a
lot of the times you talk about work a
lot of the times they're required to be
in the property for a lot longer because
they are they are actually providing a
service here as well as well as well as
Roseau and so a lot of the time they're
actually required to be in the property
a lot more which makes certain jobs not
actually possible but it's very useful
for certain people you just want to stay
at home and I know if there are I want
to be a budding writer or an artist or
someone like that then then it really
suits their lifestyle but you know it's
not for everyone it's not for people who
need stability but for people who want
to make those savings they should they
should they should have the option I
think okay Sam Dmitry from the Adam
Smith Institute many thanks indeed for
joining us this morning thank you